have you ever tried to hold a staring
contest with a rock if you did you might
not have expected that all that time you
were staring at one of the sneakiest
shapeshifters in the world
no rocks don't shapeshift into unicorns
but they do change shape and composition
sometimes they change quickly like when
an erupting volcano launches molten rock
into the air and sometimes they change
slowly like when a rock is heated and
compressed in the earth for thousands to
millions of years
when geologists stare at a rock they can
figure out the rock's composition and
tell the story of how it was created and
it turns out rocks can be made in many
different ways
when put it the right combination of
heat and pressure rocks can become
molten and liquid when this molten rock
cools and becomes solid we call the
rocket makes igneous rock this term
comes from the latin word igneous which
means fiery or burning hot
igneous rocks make up more than 90
of the earth's crust one common kind of
igneous rock is granite which you've
probably seen in bridges buildings and
countertops
another kind of igneous rock is obsidian
which is smooth and glassy and is
sometimes used to make knife blades both
of these rocks were made of molten rock
so why do they look so different
well granite was made from magma which
is molten rock that exists below the
surface of the earth magma tends to cool
slowly underground which gives time for
the elements in it to form large
crystals and this obsidian rock was made
from lava which is molten rock that
flows above the ground lava tends to
cool quickly which causes the rocks it
forms like obsidian to have smaller
crystals
i always remember the difference between
magma and lava like this i keep my lava
lamp above the ground just like lava is
above the ground if i buried my lava
lamp in the ground then i can call it a
magma lamp once an igneous rock is
created its journey isn't over the rock
might begin to change through a process
called weathering this is when water
weather wind and other physical forces
chip away at a rock and cause little
pieces to break off these little
particles are called sediments
the sediment from our igneous rock can
be moved around by wind and water this
is called erosion
eventually the sediment will settle down
somewhere maybe at the bottom of an
ocean or a lake and it might join other
sediment from other rocks crushed up
shells and plant matter and over time
this sediment will become a rock rocks
that are formed from sediments are
called you guessed it sedimentary rocks
but how does sedimentary goop at the
bottom of a lake become a rock
well it goes through a process called
lithification lith comes from the greek
word for stone so you can think of this
process as stonification the first step
of lithification is called deposition
this is when sediment is deposited in a
new location and it spreads out to form
a layer
as more and more layers are created the
layers underneath them become squished
together
this is called compaction when water
moves to the layers of sediment it can
carry dissolved minerals with it the
water can leave these minerals in
between the sediment particles which
makes everything stick together this
cementing of sediment is called
cementation
limestone is a sedimentary rock that is
made when sediment that contains a lot
of calcium carbonate in it goes through
lithification
but once a sedimentary rock has been
created it doesn't mean that it is done
changing
sometimes a rock is squeezed or heated
so much that the minerals inside it
actually change composition it is now a
metamorphic rock
you might have heard of the word
metamorphosis which describes when
something changes from one form and
structure to another like when a
caterpillar turns into a butterfly
metamorphic rocks are made when igneous
sedimentary or even other metamorphic
rocks change form in structure because
of heat and pressure for example when
the sedimentary rock limestone gets put
under a lot of heat and pressure it can
turn into marble but metamorphic rocks
still might not be done changing rocks
can actually keep on changing forever
igneous and metamorphic rocks can become
sedimentary rocks if they are broken
apart into sediments and go through
lithification and metamorphic rocks and
sedimentary rocks can become igneous
rocks when they are melted and then
cools and igneous rocks and sedimentary
rocks can become metamorphic rocks when
they're exposed to high heat and
pressure this is called the rock cycle
so maybe next time you get the chance to
stare at a rock see if you can figure
out whether it's igneous metamorphic or
sedimentary and when rocks change so
much who knows what kind of rock it'll
be next